I am feeling the holiday vibes in the wall.
Lee Harris put this outfit on and I literally was like,
"I look like a Christmas tree."
Like, I have a green bottom and a red top
and then he likes to put this belt on me.
I'm like,
"Am I Liz Taylor in Cleopatra or is this a belt?"
But I said,
"Okay, let's wear it."
It feels festive and that's what the holidays are all about.
Just having the chance to express yourself.
An excuse to express yourself.
And it 'tis the season and you know what that means.
It means lots of thoughts and feelings.
I mean,
I think I've been feeling a little crazy since
you know, the onset of Thanksgiving.
Halloween, I was like,
"Express and it's so awesome and cool."
And then Thanksgiving came and I was like,
(sobbing)
"It's the holidays."
It's just a hard time this year, you know?
There are all the feelings involved
and it's a weird holiday season,
and hopefully it will be one year.
Hope I think is on the way and around the corner,
and in some ways that's a great reason
to almost embrace this even more
and not act like this is forever.
I do believe this is temporary.
I talk to my kids about it all the time.
I also think it's a time we should take advantage of
to do things a little differently.
Since we are forced into this,
what could we do that will make this a very memorable time?
Like remember the year we had to do it this way?
So I always like turning a difficult into a positive
and I also love talking to you guys
and doing something that we call "Drew & A"
because we tie my name with everything.
So does anyone have a holiday related question?
Let's see here.
Oh, Bianca.
Hi.
(laughing)
Um, oh my gosh.
That is so cute.
In fact, I'm like,
(whistling)
"Where are my dogs?"
They're traipsing around the building somewhere.
Who is that?
This is Bourdain.
He's a Cavalier King Charles Spaniel.
He is seven months old.
Oh, he is show cute.
Oh, he's young!
Seven months.
Still very much a puppy.
Well, um, sorry.
I keep going on and on about your doggy.
May I ask what your question is, Bianca?
Yeah.
So, you know,
holidays are gonna be a little different this year.
My husband's deployed.
I live super close to my in-laws and they've done so much
for the family and with my husband not being here,
I'm the one in charge of gifts.
I'm just wondering what would be something special
to get them this year?
Okay.
Well, my immediate thought is something personalized.
Always something they cannot buy in a store.
I think since you're trying to be the glue of the family,
maybe keeping it about the family rather
than something that doesn't really have to do
with the family and just feels like a gift.
So I wanna give this some thought
but whatever it's gonna be,
I'm gonna say pictures, engraving,
like something that's really about how
to make your in-laws feel like
they're surrounded in the family.
Your particular family.
I wanna make it personal and I'm gonna give you an answer
at the end of the show.
Does that sound good?
Sounds good.
Also, if you don't mind, can I help you do it?
(giggling)
Okay.
Okay, good.
I'm like,
how do you feel about me getting personally involved?
We've actually taken it upon ourselves
to think about Bianca's question from earlier
and we have two ideas.
One from me and one from Ross.
Bianca?
There you are.
Hi.
I love you, Ross.
I love you, Drew, oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, thank you so much.
Look how cute.
I know,
with her little King Charles.
We've been thinking very seriously about what
to do for your relatives for Christmas.
Mm hmm.
Okay, I think that you should get a series of mugs
and the reason why is because it's usually something
that everybody holds in their hands every day.
I know I do.
Case in point.
Literally.
So I would like you
to select four special family photographs
that includes everybody
so that your in-laws can actually feel it,
hold it,
and look at it every single day.
I love that.
And something that my mom's best friend did for me
before my mom passed away,
she got all of her recipes and printed them out
and made a little cookbook
with like my mom's recipes and my Nana's.
So I have that,
those treasured recipes forever and ever, and ever.
It's one-of-a-kind, you know?
Ross, that is such a good idea.
Good, I treasure it.
So what do you think, Bianca?
I think that's a great idea,
especially with my husband being deployed and not here.
I think that would be,
like mean everything to them.
So.
Okay, great.
So we're gonna send you a $500 gift card just
to get it all done,
get right on top of it,
it's on us.
And please extend our very best to your very brave
and wonderful husband who's off and deployed.
And Bianca,
your in-laws,
no matter what you give them,
what a lucky set of parents they are
to have a daughter-in-law like you.
(laughing)
Thank you.
And everyone else in our VFS,
thank you for bringin' the spirit today
and to anyone watching at home,
thank you for joining Ross and I.
We wish you a wonderful rest of your day.
Take this with you.
(audience clapping)
Bye, everybody.
Thank you, everybody.
Bye.
(upbeat music)